[موسيقى]
هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا
بكم نفت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه
سيطره القوات الروسيه على مدينه باخموت
وقالت انها تتصدح للكثير من الهجمات
المعاديه وكان بريكوجين رئيس شركه فاجنر
قال ان مقاتليه رفعوا العلم الروسي ورايه
قوته على المبنى الاداري في مركز ضخمه
قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي انه تم
استدعاء مروحيات ومقاتلات حربيه في اعقاب
رصد مسير مجهوله تسللت من الاراضي السوريه
الى داخل الاجواء الاسرائيليه واضاف انه
تم اسقاط المسيره في منطقه مفتوحه دون ان
تشكل اي خطر بدورها قالت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان المسيره التي دخلت من جهه
سوريا يشتبه في انها ايرانيه
نقلت وكاله الانبياء السوريه سان عن مصدر
في الشرطه دمشق انفجارا وقع في منطقه
المزي قرب العاصمه واضافت الوكاله ان عبوه
ناسفه انفجرت بسياره مدنيه وقد استبعدت
مصادر اسرائيليه ان تكون هناك علاقه لتل
ابيب بانفجار السياره
اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل مستشار
عسكري اخر بعد اصابته بجروح في غاره
اسرائيليه على ضواحي العاصمه السوريه فجر
الجمعه وقد شدد الحرس على ان ما سماها
جريمه الكيان الصهيوني المجرم لن تمر
دونرت
اعلنت الحكومه الاسرائيليه انشاء الحرس
الوطني في وزاره الامن القوميه واضافت
الحكومه ان الحرس الوطني سيتعامل مع حالات
الطوارئ الوطنيه مثل الاضطرابات اثناء
عمليه حارس الاسوار
من جانب قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه ان
حكومه نتنياهو قلت ميزانيات الصحه
والتعليم
لتمويل جيش من البلطجيه وميليشيا خاصه
لوزير الامن القومي
نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن وزيره
النقل في حكومه نتنياهو قولها ان الحكومه
ستستانف العمل على مشروع التعديلات
القضائيه بعد عيد الاستقلال مباشره حسب
قولها
اقتحمت قوه من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
شارع المخفيه عند اطراف مدينه نابلس
اعتقلت فلسطينيين وفق مصادر اسرائيليه
وقال شهود عيان ان عمليه الاقتحام كانت
خاطفه ولم تستمر الا لدقائق ودارت خلالها
اشتباكات محدوده مع مقاومين فلسطيني
افادتورز بارتفاع يسار النفط باكثر من 6%
وذلك بعد اعلان عدد من الدول العربيه
المنضويه تحت مظله الى جانب روسيا عن
تخفيض طوعي في انتاجها نفطي اعتبارا من ما
يغير القادم وحتى نهايه العامه بينما قال
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
انه لا يعتقد ان التخفيضات هذه منطقيه في
هذا التوقيت نظرا لعدم اليقين في السوق
الى اللقاء